[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
耳を澄ませてみてください
あなたには何が聞こえますか
心の中で時計の針の音は聞こえますか
毎秒私たちの人生の時間は刻まれていき
ます
その限られた時間の中で
自分だけの火をともして
その日の明かりで見えてくる道があると
いうことを今日私はみなさんにお伝えし
たいと思いますマツダカールですお願いし
ます
ライダーファイヤで cad ぷダウトゥ
誰にも消せない火を灯して人生は1度きり
今あなたがしたいことなりたい自分は何
ですか
私は3歳のころから祖父と一緒によく戦艦
ヤマトや戦闘機の絵を書いていました
祖父は指で鉛筆をぼかしたりしてそういう
書き方を祖父と一緒に真似しながら書くの
が好きでよく遊んでいました
小さい頃とても恥ずかしがりやで私はよく
人ではなく
きや竹やぶに話しかけていました
そんな方いらっしゃいますか一緒のような
方はいらっしゃいますか
あいらっしゃった素晴らしい後でお話し
ましょうにするねっ
そんな子だったんですけど
母や父の帰りが十分でもそういうときは庭
に生えている4本の木にこう言ってました
お願いしますお母さんとお父さんを無事
送り届けてください
そう言うとさぁさぁと風が吹いてきが
揺れる
それだけで安心していました
その気にシロアリが湧いて引っこ抜かれた
時はしくしく涙を流しました
修了式の帰り道私は
重たい絵の具セットと習字灯具を持って
ヨロヨロ帰っていましたそしてたまたま
自分の指でその日自分の目を傷つけた
傷つけてしまったこともあって
痛くて重くて全部が重なってよろよろと
竹やぶの道を帰っていましたこれ実際の私
の帰り道なんですけど小学校の時の
ああ痛いよーいたい想いよう滝矢部さん
どうか私に背中から追い風を吹かせて助け
てください
そう言うと坂道の下からさあと風が吹いて
私の背中を優しく押してくれる
ありがとう
そんな子でした
そして私は
小学校6年生のころ
担任の先生が母を呼び出してこんなことを
言われます
カルチャーのお母さん
カールちゃんが突拍子もない事ばかりを
言ってクラスのみんなをゾンビ化せてい
ます
このままだと大変です
そう言いました
私は
そんなの言われても自覚症状がないので
どうしようもなくて
そのまま私は中学校に上がります
すると
周りのみんなが私を避けるようになって
先生の忠告が当たったのか
私はとうとう一人ぼっちになってしまい
ました
つらくてつらくて
ん
めちゃめちゃ辛くてもういいに閉じこもっ
て歌ばかり歌ってたりぼーっと海を眺め
たり
家の裏の林が真っ赤に燃えた夕日どんどん
沈んでいく中飼っていた犬と向かい風に
向かって走り抜けたり
そうな様子を見ていた母が私にこんなこと
を言いました
薫
人の心を動かすことって難しいことだね
みんなの心を動かせるといいのにね
私はその時から淡路島にいるといろんな風
が吹くことを感じていました
やがて社会人になり私はいろんな職業に
就きます
医療事務だったり
建設事務あとは
なんだっけ何
あ
嘘外相の自分
いろんな職業に就くんですけども
なぜか私が触れた機械がことごとく壊れて
いくんです
申し訳なくて
ああの
まあ申し訳なさすぎるんであの私なんても
クビにしてくださいって会社で大きな声で
泣いたこともありましたし
もうほんと何も出来なくて運送会社の事務
では社長がもう増田版の好きなようにし
てくれって
そういって言うからあのー青木れまし
たっててでオーターサーバーあの営業の方
がいらっしゃって家の機会おいてください
好きにしていって言われたもんだから全然
いいと思いますって言って社長室行って
社長の机開けて一番上にある一番使ってい
そうな通帳を取り出して社長グラ一番
運行力の強そうな大きい四角いラッカーに
待って取り出して板て契約したんですね
3そしたら会社全体がさすがにドン引き
ました
それにはまあ私はさすがに気づきました
まあもうます打破
もうあかーんもうあの犬の散歩でもしとっ
てくれ
わかりましたそう言われてと叫んの散歩し
に外に出ました
ああ私ほんと何もできないや
私に何ができるんだろう
うルールとした夕日がゆっくり炎のように
染まって沈んでいきます
私はリードを保ってじーっと佇んでいると
田んぼの稲穂の隙間からさー風が吹いてき
て私の背中ねや刺し口
こうやって
当たる気配がしました
控えめに大丈夫って言ってるような感じ
そしてふと足元を見ると
とさけんが私の革靴をガーガーを噛んでい
ました
あもう飯を食べてもう私何もできないし
食べられて当然なんです私なんてあ食べて
くださいどうぞ
まもなくしてその会社は
まずだ版も今でかマン境にその一言でクビ
になりました
こんなダメダメな私にある時転機が訪れ
ます
それは
遠く離れた所に住んでいるお友達が結婚し
ますという素晴らしい朗報が入りました
私はすぐに気持ちをお届けしたくて
友達に何を贈ろうかなそう思った矢先に
iphone で指で絵を描くソフトを
見つけたんですそれはとてもシンプルな
もので指で線を書いて色を塗るそして似顔
絵ができるそれをデータにしてポンって
離れている友達に送れるんです
すると友人が大変喜んでくれて
そして
みるみるうちに口コミで広がってへの依頼
が私なんかに入るようになりました
あるしは嬉しくて嬉しくてそこからホテル
だったりイベント会場あとはお店
いろんなところで似顔絵パフォーマンスを
させていただくことになりましたうん
こんな私なんかに
への依頼が来るなんて
そしてやがて約年間1000人の似顔絵を
書かせて頂くまでになりましたん
私は
自分のできること
やっと見つかったと思って本当に嬉しくて
絵を描くこと1本で生計を立てれるように
なった頃私はもっと自分の持つ可能性を
追求したい
そう思って油絵をかけ始めます
何をどう使っていいか分からずに
とりあえずキャンバスと向き合ってそこに
ある油絵具だったりをいろんなものを使っ
て書いてみするとこんな絵が出来ました
この時
わたしの心に秘めているもの
あとは私の持ってた香具師
どんどん溢れ出る感情を覚えてみるみる
うちに私は油絵に夢中になります
それと同時に
私は
とても大切な人なくすことになります
それは
私に小さい頃から絵を教えてくれた大好き
な祖父
お医者さんから
あと1年しか生きられないと言われ
私の心の中で初めてこの時時計の針の音が
刻まれる感覚を覚えました
そこから私はがむしゃらに絵を書いて毎日
祖父に会い抜き祖父の手を握るそれにてし
ました
そして私が書いた絵を祖父に見せるすると
祖父がそれを写真でコピーして看護師さん
や介護士さんたちに見せるんですそして
こう言います
私の孫はこんなに絵がうまいんだぞって
それが祖父の喜びだったんです
私は
時計の針に逆らうようにがむしゃらに書い
て開店
祖父に見せる
それを続けました
良質の窓から冷たい秋の風が頬を伝います
がむしゃらに書くんですが時計の針は
止まってくれません
とうとう大好きだった祖父はいなくなって
しまいました
私は映画書くことができず悲しみにくれ
毎日
歌を歌ってピアノ弾いて歌を歌って悲しさ
を紛らわせていました
そんなとき
sns をで私のその様子を見た人たちが
こんなことを言ってくれます
負けないで応援してるからおじいちゃん
ずっと見てくれてるから
そう言われて私は祖父を持ってある一つの
作品を書きますそれは
装具と昔よく一緒に変えた戦闘機
題名は
静かな覚悟
人は
避けられない運命に立ちはだかった時
もがいてもがいても書疲れてやがて一筋の
光の中に入る
その瞬間
覚悟を決めるんです
私はこの操縦士と
絵を教えてくれた祖父を持って敬意を表し
てこれを書きました
そしてこのときどれだけ人の心を動かす
ことができるかこれを人生の目標に掲げ
とある美術協会の大会に出品する覚悟を
決めました
ですが
その美術協会の大会で私のこの作品は陰の
方の見えないところに飾られていました
あれなんで
正直にそう思いました
そしてたまたま
震災の方とお話する機会があったので私は
正直に聞きました
どうして私の絵はここに飾られているん
ですか
すると震災の方がこんなことを言います
美術の世界にはり方というものがあって海
と空を一対一で書くこと
これすなわちタブーなんです
それに
被写体この日講義こんなにちっちゃく書い
てこれだったら書かないほうがいい
ないほうが良かった
だからあなたの作品は審査外なんです
なるほど
そういうことか
ああだったら私は自分の書きたいものを心
に秘めているものを自分の書き方で自由に
自己流で我流で書いて表現する私の人生
それをそれに時間を費やそうってそう心に
決めました私の心の中に灯した炎がより
一層燃え上がる瞬間でした
それからというもの
私は淡路島を拠点にいろんな会社さんの
看板や壁画を書かせて頂き学びをいただき
似顔絵イラストキャラクター
そこから気づきをいただき絵が描けない時
はピアノ弾いてがむしゃらに歌を歌い
キャンバスと向かい合って切り移り変わる
時間を絵の具に変えて淡路島から登場南北
本社線状に広がる風をイメージして書いて
書いてがむしゃらに書いて
やっと3年越しに
ある一つの作品が出来ました
私の日々移り変わる
時間を絵の具に書いて1作品
底なしの石田多分
私はこれをもって
また再び
美術協会の大会に挑戦する決心をしました
それに私は
勝ちに出ていました絶対覆してみせる
そう思って出展しました結果
その五術協会の大会で
特選という賞をいただくことができました
正直やった口が得てたって思いました
本当に嬉しくて
ここから私の歯車は回り出します
自分の持っている可能性をもっと追求し
たい
いろんな人の心を動かしたい
そう思って村が使っていた筆を使って水墨
画や
いろんな絵を書きます
戦国武将だったり
虎や龍の絵を誰もやってない水墨と
コーヒーを混ぜ合わせて自分にしかでき
ない表現で次々に作品を生み出します
自分の秘めているものそれを全部作品にし
ましたするとその様子を見ていた
sns の人たちがう
薫の活動に勇気をもらったから自分も
頑張るだったり
今まで目を背けていたことにもう一度
向き合う覚悟が出来ましただったり
ありがとう薫と
日本のみならず世界各国でいろんな方々が
私にエールを下さるそんな現象が起き始め
ました
私はできる限り現地の言葉でおじいさんや
おばあさんそしてともに挑戦する人たち
そして夢いっぱいの子どもたち
できましね中国語と英語も勉強して
話しかけて返事をして分け隔てなく友達に
お見せしました
そんなとき
とある美術協会から
水墨画の展示の依頼が来て2020年
東京新国立美術館に展示する運びとなり
その後2021年
台湾の芸術の祭典対日芸術博覧会にて日本
から選抜で選んでいただき
そこで私の作品は台湾に展示することに
なりましたしかし
この中で私は行くことができませんでした
私は一転やはり源氏の皆さんに直接作品を
説明したりふれあいたかった
だけど行くことができませんでした
さあここで私は黙っていません
床を非常にためておいたお金を
めいっぱいその sns 広告につぎ込ん
で台湾全域にばらまきました
そしてそのチラシの内容には日本の淡路島
の増田薫と
私の情報をぎゅっと詰め込んで拡散しまし
た
そしてできましない中国語英語
もうわからないまま合ってるかどうかも
わからないも話して動画にして pr し
てたじゃ歯を黄ジャン早稲田薫合ってるか
どうかわからないですねうそーやって
みんなに pr して話しかけましたする
とどこからともなく日本の淡路島のますあ
薫をサポートしたいそういう声が届いて
台湾の皆さんがたくさんの人々が
台湾の展示場に私の絵を見に行って
くださり感想くださいそしてサラに
パイナップルケーキを送ってくださいまし
た
めちゃくちゃ美味しかったですえっ
そしてそれと同時進行にアメリカや
インドネシアからカールの活動に元気を
もらったから一緒に歌いましょうとか者の
方からお声をいただき
コラボレーションで歌わせてもらいました
ここで皆さんが言い始めます
増田薫に会いに青獅子麻衣子
薫の絵を見に淡路島に公郁と歌いたいから
淡路島に行こ
私の思いは淡路島の風にのって国境を超え
ました
そしてその風が追い風となって私の背中を
優しく押してくれるそう信じて私は今日も
明日も朝ても絵を書き続けたいとそう思っ
ています
1 day アンファン中 go all
over the world with
my ピクチャ
そして
2021年夏
私は小さい頃からずっと敬意を持っていた
そしてずっと感謝をお届けしたかった場所
内閣防衛省防衛大臣政務官室にブルーイン
パレスの絵を展示することができました
どれだけ人の心を動かすことが出来るか人
は本気を出したら何でもできるんじゃなく
て
何か変えることができる
そして決して諦めないこと自分の信念を
しっかり持ってそこで納得しないことこそ
が皆さんの可能性と出会える
そういうことだと思っています
ライダーファイヤーデイキャンとプラウド
誰にも消せ代表とまして
皆さん耳を澄ませてみてください皆さんの
中で時計の針の音が聞こえたら崩壊がない
ように伝えたいことを誰かに伝えて
ください
淡路島の風が皆さんの勇気を見守ってくれ
ています
阿波市 ran is inside
オーバー see ああ
part アースアイラー
私たちは常に良い味島の中に
ありがとうございます研究
[拍手]